welcome to the across the spoiler ver
podcast I'm your host Paul AKA Kevin
spoilers joined Once More by Greg from
real rejects Greg it's been an
absolutely crazy weekend I think Martin
scores ay he was both right and wrong
about Marvel at one point this weekend I
don't I don't think I've been called an
MCU hater or an MCU shill this much as I
have been this entire weekend it's been
an absolute nightmare uh but how how's
it been for you Greg pleasant as hell
Paul I'm having a great week
man yeah what an insane weekend I don't
think I've ever seen so much of how the
MCU is saved and how the MCU is dead
both in like one day one just took two
releases to get the conversation on both
going and yeah I did a live I'm excited
to talk more about the Marvels yet again
man the discourse on this has been very
very rough very rough to deal to
interact with is kind of what I'm
talking about but well I I did a tweet
today saying the the MCU is basically
shring as MCU in that it's both in a
state of being alive and dead and it's
only upon being observed that one can
decide and even making a joke about that
I got backlash from people Greg I had to
block someone because they were they
were call calling me names and stuff and
I don't like blocking people and I
rarely ever do it but it was getting to
that point where I just couldn't be
bothered people not even reading
subtexts and fortunately I think there's
been a lot of that this weekend you know
whenever anyone's put their opinion out
about something you're going to get
lumped in with either being a hater or a
shill and yeah it's been insane to talk
about but we've got a pretty we're going
to try and tackle it with some new on
guys and we've got a very stack show so
we're gonna be talking we're gonna be
talking about Loki um first off I want
to start the show off with a nice nice
positive thing um and brand new breaking
news that apparently Jonathan majes is
out as Kang we're then going to talk
about some Marvel delays and then why
the Marvel's bombed so you know we're
going from nice going through all the
the Dynamics of what being a Marvel fan
is like um I've put together lots of
different reasons that I've been
thinking about over the weekend um and
personally I think it's just you know
Death By A Thousand Cuts I don't think
there's one overriding reason but I
think there's several reasons to why not
everything went as well as it could have
gone and we're then going to follow that
up with the rebel Moon trailer the
coyote versus Acme big Scandal thing and
lastly on a positive note in that the
strikes are now over so yeah lots of
stuff to talk about let's just get into
Loki Greg how are you feeling about that
Paul Paul hold on there's a note here
that says you are away next week what
are you talking about yes so next week
I'm going on holiday um I was going to
ask you if you wanted to record it
another night but just in case we don't
get a chance to do that if the podcast
isn't out next week we're probably being
killed by a Marvel hater or a Marvel
shill and they've covered it up and made
it look like we're away so if I'm not
back in two weeks call the police okay
we'll figure it out well I'm supposed to
be gone for a couple days too so it
might just work in my favor and honestly
me leaving my whole stress was based off
of is Paul G to be mad at me if we can't
record since he does more work for this
podcast than I do so it might it might
just bring me some relief so yeah all
right man you asked me what I thought
about Loki season 2 I thought it was
beautiful it was grandiose epic uh
moving cements itself as my favorite
Disney plus Marvel series and you know
it's like Loki then W division for sure
and and an ending that you know some
people predicted it might go down that
way but it's more of
the I mean you can kind of say the same
thing about the criticism for the
Marvels but in the opposite direction
it's the like I I know you had some
theories for how it would go down it
seemed to go down the path of those
theories but it's the manner in which
the matter is executed you know and I
think the way they went about it
actually unfolded in ways that I didn't
ultimately expect it to uh but yeah it
was just epic and so moving and talk
about it's it's so great that Tom hon
can have two separate lokis the one that
was in the movies and the one in the
show and have two character arcs for
them and then just to cement himself as
just one of the greatest performances in
all of the MCU I I think I think any of
the criticisms I had about Loki season 2
as as well along the journey I thought
got alleviated by the end too you know I
I thought it was so thought it was Grand
and congratulations on the success of
your breakdowns for it man your videos
were oh thank you you too you had a very
stressful time I know because you were
getting copyright strikes and stuff but
it I mean overall we've done pretty well
out of it and I've enjoyed covering it
um I actually went back and rewatched
season two because what had happened is
I'd watched the first two episodes with
my wife um and then we we both kind of
just went off and did her own thing so I
just kept watching it obviously for my
job whereas she didn't get to see it so
I went back and watched it with her and
there's actually an insane amount of
foreshadowing in it once you know the
ending um like random trees popping up
for example the one in the McDonald's in
the 80s um if you look at when Victor
timy's on stage during the the 1800s the
background of him on the stage that's
loads of different trees and stuff and
there's so many different lines in it um
raona at one point she talks about
something like Mobius I kept this thing
going because I could do the things that
you didn't have to and obviously later
we find out she was willing to kill
children and stuff and yeah there's
watching the season for a second time
it's absolutely incredible and I'm gonna
milk gonna milk the crap out of it this
week with videos um as I say I'm away
next week so I'm just I'm just talking
about things I love um but brilliant
really really good and just the amount
of things that kind of tie back to the
MCU I kind of see it almost in the same
way that um um endgame kind of
capitalized on lots of different lines
Lac throughout the the MCU when you go
back and watch things that Lok he said
throughout the Saga pretty much every
single property that he's been in at
some point he's mentioned a chair or a
throne or even his first one of his
first lines in The Avengers film is him
basically saying it's my burden to carry
this glorious purpose and for them to
pull it all together for this finale
fantastic work just seeing him sitting
on the throne carrying the burden going
from someone who in The Avengers was
very much against Free Will and he
wanted to take everyone's Freedom away
and mind control them and stuff to now
being this person who's giv everyone
Free Will holding the Multiverse
together brilliant I really really can't
overstate how good I thought that it was
and even better on a second watch and it
kind of shows you know it's it this is
the reason why we fell in love with
Marvel these kind of stories where they
take these Heroes on incredible arcs you
know well Loki was a villain in the
first place anyway but for him to to go
on this Arc brilliant um Tom hson
knocked it out the park and yeah just
everything that I wanted from this show
and above that to be honest I wasn't
expecting I think we've had so many
Marvel projects that the final episodes
kind of been where the show Almost Falls
flat there's there's very few brilliant
final episodes in the Disney plus MCU
series but this just went insane um and
yeah loved it really really enjoyed it
what I think is really cool about the
way this season went down as well you
know a lot of people I've been seeing on
especially on social media have been
going like the loky arc over the Iron
Man Arc and it's an interesting thing to
kind of compare because Iron Man was one
that they impro they sort of improvised
it as the phases went along you know
they didn't plan like from the second
the first Iron Man came out how they
were going to have Tony Stark exit the
MCU and what his ultimate sacrifice will
be that would tie in for a great
character Arc for him throughout the
phases I I really love the art that he
has but you know they didn't even think
about Thanos until there was a post
credit scene that seemed to click with
people in Avengers like hey maybe we
should actually follow through with this
you know and with Loki season 2 what's
really interesting to me is how it was
only till recently uh post like during
the writers strike and all that how they
decided you know we should get a
showrunner in here to really map out and
such and this really felt like they had
a showrunner because there was such a
Clear Vision where they could really
they could really map out what Loki's
Arc would be for season 2 I think it's
great how in the beginning something
that I was nitpicky about admittedly was
I was feeling like I was missing out a
bit on some of Loki's mischievous
personality not that I needed him to go
like full mischievous or anything like
that it it just he just seems so like
kind of serious but then by the time I
got the ending episode I thought it just
served the story that much better the
the way how his entire portrayal went
down in season 2 because at the
beginning of this season he's just a
full-blown TVA agent with powers
basically is who he is and he's so much
more in touch with Humanity at that
point like he feels more human at the
start of season two than any other time
we've ever hung out with Loki he's not
really using his powers he really cares
about his human Companions and then for
to become the the leader who's going to
just look after everyone you needed that
type of human touch and to think about
the trajectory from season one of how
it's just been this deconstruction to
how he goes from you know um god of
Mischief to God of Stories the arc to
that feels completely natural it felt
earned it didn't just feel like they had
to do it like you really strip down Loki
to his core and I think the way they
Pace the show with its unque style where
a lot of people like myself included I
don't know how far you got into Doctor
Who but this this last episode
especially reminded me of a very popular
Peter kapali episode of Doctor Who where
he does have to keep he's around for
like a million years or something like
that he has to keep reliving it and
learning and he keeps dying every time
and I thought that by the time we got to
this this ending point for Loki
everything just felt really earned and
not only that they they also had some
great it kind of felt like an
independent movie that kind of bitter
melancholic tone that it had for that
like that ethereal type of music that
was playing over as they were montaging
around between Mobius and the choice
that he makes and then even with ravona
I saw your video uh I I thought on my
live stream I was like referencing some
things that you were pointing out in
your
video about like raona with with
possibly not seeing elith but seeing
King at the end of time I thought that
was a really great call but even that
just like the way they leaned on mood
and tone and pacing was it it was quite
beautiful and on top of that too the
visual effects were were incredibly like
there were something to behold I was in
awe yeah of it I'll kiss this Show's ass
all day long I thought it was excellent
yeah I didn't really think there were
any flows in the the CGI um I I thought
the character rocks were brilliant I
thought the acting was brilliant there
was very little that I could criticize
it for you know watching it again
there's some slight slower paced part of
the season but nitpicking um I think if
you're watching it week to week how we
we had it it works brilliantly um but
even on a binge it's still really strong
and it's nice to see the MCU taking
themselves seriously um the way they end
it as well you know we know that K it
was meant to be coming down the line but
the way they ended it I feel like they
could kind of brush him off to the side
if needs be and just be like yeah we're
just keeping an eye on him um how's the
trial going with Jonathan maor just on a
a totally different unrelated tangent
like oh he's he's still in trial like
okay well we're just keeping an eye on
him over here then we'll just keep
keeping an eye and then if he gets found
innocent they're like oh no the Loki
couldn't hold things together but if
he's found guilty then they're gonna be
like we just still keeping keeping an
eye on K but that kind of Maj was great
man all things said he was great in it
so if this is his last appearance then
all right he was he was excellent and in
it I I loved his return as he who
remains we gave a different side I
thought was great just the twist in that
scene as well where you realize he's
been through it before and he kind of
knows exactly what's coming and that
this is just part of the loop very very
nice twist in it but um yeah speaking of
Jonathan Mages as K according to uh the
podcast I just listened to this to make
sure that it was exactly what they're
saying um because you know how they can
kind of run away with stuff but yeah so
the the house of R the Ring of ver
podcast um they basically did a Loki
season 2 episode six deep dive um I
think it was and at the one or the twoh
hour 58 Mark um they basically talk
about how from what they've heard Jeff
lovess was told by Marvel Studios that
they're likely moving away from the K
storyline which is why he was no longer
writing Avengers K Dynasty um so that
that's just as we're recording this this
literally dropped 10 minutes before I
hit record so it's quite a new story
it's developing
quickly just skipped to that time code
um because it was posted on Reddit to
make sure that that was definitely what
was said um there are Outlets kind of
running with with it as being an
official announcement that's fact um but
Jeff lovess hasn't out and out said it
himself it's coming through through um
Jonah Robinson on the podcast I believe
um so got it we we'll have to see but
it's it's kind of you know it may I mean
yeah there's a lot of stuff going on
with that personally I mean I I'm still
very much of the Mind state that this
trial is in black and white and I
they've been holding off for for a long
time and haven't made a statement even
you know when things developed and Loki
was coming out and stuff so um we'll see
what happens but I I still believe
innocent until proven guilty in that
they should wait off until there's a
verdict and not just buy the guy and get
rid of him um but in the same breath I
can understand why they're having to do
this because it's such a big risk to to
wait it out and see how this whole thing
goes when you're building towards Big
phase I really think though I don't know
I imagine this is not a popular opinion
I know that some people do share this
opinion I'm just saying I don't know if
it's the majority if he is found guilty
and they ultimately have to fire
Jonathan major I am not opposed to
recasting King you know we've we've had
so many of the stories that are
specifically building up to some type of
ultimate King Showdown with the Avengers
there's just been too many of that sort
of Lac throughout and when when there's
so much debate about what is the
direction of this Multiverse Saga and it
it just seems like it'd be odd to
completely just drop it while while your
exit plan can happen via what happens in
Loki season two sure I still think that
you can kind of stick to the plan a
little bit and just recast him if if you
need to I'm not saying do it pre outcome
of trial I'm saying if he's found guilty
then consider it I don't think you need
to completely eliminate
it yeah I 100% agree um but I also
wonder if Marvel kind of feel like they
they fumbled the ball a bit with how
they handled Kang in the beginning
because let's be honest there there's
not that respect there that there was
for someone like Thanos or something you
know there's not that fear when you're
approaching a k it's kind of like he's a
crazy whack who we're going to see this
week who's going to get killed off and I
think they you know
the the Council of kangs that whole post
credit scene was kind of I personally
didn't like the tone of it I thought it
was almost like I remember you saying it
was like an SNL sketch and I felt that
as well I thought Ant-Man beating that
Kang was difficult um but I can totally
see what basically guys in case you
don't know the rumors behind the scenes
were that Jonathan majes and K weren't
meant to be the big thing that they were
all building towards but the behind the
scenes everyone was so blown away by him
on Loki season one in the that they
thought oh Jesus we' found them we've
got the next big big billing of the
phase so they kind of leaned into that
obviously they must be regretting it
well I think what the movies need to
demonstrate because a lot of times
people come down to the defense of
quantum Mania the choice like he's not
about the strength though he's not like
Thanos and that I'm like I'm aware I'm
fully aware that that is the point
however that's what the loky show leaned
into on both appearances by he who
remains you know they're very he gives a
different shade to he who remains at the
end of season one and at the end of
season two when you compare the
performances as that same
variant what makes that version of he
who remains so scary is that a there's
no fear in him he he's in such control
and he's hyper hyper intelligent and
that's what needs to be demonstrated not
even Quantum Mania really showcases that
as great of a as much as he's the scene
stealer as much as he brings like an
aura to his performance like the the
Menace and those like his the best
scenes are with him the hyper
intelligence and the the the the
foresight that he has is the is the
thing that makes Kang truly threatening
where he can outwit a Thanos he might
not be able to outow a Thanos but he can
outwit him and out strategize him and
that's what the movies need to show and
maybe not enough people are watching the
Loki show I have no idea but it it
really comes across when Jonathan major
is specifically portraying he who
remains and that's what I think what we
need is like a prime King some some type
of King to really zero in on is while
there's a bunch of variants there's this
one very specific one that we have to
fear you know yeah no it's very strange
I mean obviously the movie's not even
going to release until probably another
four years because moving on to our next
topic we've had lots of different delays
with Marvel so yeah big delays um some
are saying because of the strike
personally I think there's other reasons
but Deadpool 3 will now release on July
26 2024 Captain America 4 will release
February 14th 2025 Thunderbolts will
release July 25th 2025 blade will
release November 7th 2025 and I'm sure
there's another MCU movie in that year
the year is going to be stacked um 2025
next year though we're only getting the
one MCU movie which I'm actually
grateful of I think you know Deadpool 3
just build up to it like it's a massive
massive event hu Hubert Jackman he back
baby um Patrick Stewart probably back
Beast CGI Beast coming back post credit
scenes yeah um so yeah I I think that's
a good way to take things we have heard
that there were was a test screening of
Captain America 4 apparently it was
terrible um and they've just realized oh
we need four months of re-shoot
obviously Marvel always build re-shoot
into their their production schedule
anyway but for it to get delayed almost
an entire year I believe that's insane
um but it just goes to show you know I
think Marvel have kind of hit a point
where they're like crap we need to
re-evaluate what the hell we're doing
because the audience numbers are
dropping off quick and this weekend's
been a big big approver of that um so do
you think this is a good move to delay
everything or are you annoyed Greg like
I need that sweet Marvel stuff I think
it's a great we have to get back to a
point where we miss Marvel and if
Deadpool 3 sticks The Landing if it's
great and that makes all of us want more
they got to let us the
audience really marinade in that feeling
of wanting and so you got to have dead
it's like I'm really looking forward to
I was thinking about the franchises I'm
really looking forward to Spider-Man 4
because even though we've had other
Spiderman properties like the across the
spiderverse films and the Spider-Man
games it's been a while since no way
home you know like all things considered
it's been it's been a while since no way
home and the fact that they haven't even
started shooting it yet is not a cause
for concern Because by the time we
actually get that first trailer it's
going to be exciting that Spider-Man is
back on the big screen again after no
way home so if Deadpool 3 can be some
type of indicator of that where that
comes out and then it makes us like oh
we're we're in love with it because yeah
Marvel constantly flip-flops between MCU
is dead to MCU is saved constantly and
the point is to just let us simmer with
that feeling like I know there's some
shows that are still coming out Captain
America 4 I really do feel like they got
to get down right that was a film that's
been set up since Avengers endgame we
did get Falcon a winter soldier and
there's a lot of writing on that you
know a lot of people still are like when
is Steve Rogers going to come back is
Chris Evans going to come back the
Marvel's trailer even was showing Steve
Rogers all over again to the final one
and I there's a lot writing on Captain
America 4 specifically I think and I'm
I'm really for that there's I'm really
rooting for that because Anthony Mackey
has to prove himself worthy of the of
the mantle on the big screen and he's
got a lot to go up against because he's
gonna be getting compared to Chris Evans
and he has a very different type of
character so I really want it to be good
I'm I'm I'm nervous about the reception
I was going to say he was the first
recast from like the the older you know
the older Avengers I mean he sort of is
but then sh kind of took over a black
panther obviously that that's different
circumstances but this is the first one
where they purposely built an actor into
it so obviously you know there's going
to be comparisons um I'm rooting for
it I got a question for you do how do
you feel about the blade release date
being one week after Halloween I'm just
realizing that right now yeah that's a
bit strange cuz you would think they
would try and get it in the week
beforehand I mean we've just seen with
Five Nights at Freddy's how that weekend
before Halloween you kind of get your
big thing and then it all builds up
towards Halloween and strange I mean I
personally don't think it's going to hit
that release date you know I think it's
going to be one of those films that's
just constantly in development H and uh
yeah I'd be surprised if it even hits
that to be honest I mean they've put
that got released got announced four
years ago I think it was um and for it
to be now yeah coming
as the last film in 2025 when it was
announced it's been worked on that long
ago it's kind of so yeah we're going to
see personally I'll be surprised if it
hits it it's also not it doesn't feel
like it's um imperative to what's coming
down the line if that makes sense for
example when we know what we're building
towards now you know the X-Men and
Secret Wars and stuff like that um but
this doesn't feel like it necessarily
needs to be released in order to tie to
those stories
it's kind of like it's a it's a side
project in the MCU where you know if it
comes out before Secret Wars great if it
comes out after it's not really going to
change it that sort of thing Point um
how do you feel about fantastic for not
being on here yeah that's really strange
as well I mean that sounds like it's a
complete mess too I thought the casting
of that was going to get announced as
soon as the strike lifted but apparently
from what I've heard there's lots of
people behind the scenes who are turning
down the role of Reed Richards we've
heard that they're going in in a
Direction with Sue Richards and from
what I've been told is that the the male
actors who've been sold are readed
riches is going to be a big part of the
film they've realized that it's not
necessarily a massive part and it's not
what they're being sold when they read
the script they're kind of like well
Reed Richard is in this but he's not a
big part of it so we're going to be
Tiding at this thing you know what I'm
saying Interest really you look very
confused yeah that's what I heard well
it's obviously going to be we've heard
all the rumors of about being focused on
Sue Richards and perspective yeah I
heard that she it would be more she's
the
lead for Reed Richards to not really be
a part I mean it's four so you need yeah
I mean it should
be yeah but that that was what I was
told it was very soe heavy so the male
actors are kind of like oh so it's Fant
because when they get told that they're
in the running for Fantastic 4 they're
like I'm red Richards I'm going to be
the main character in M MCU movie and
then they get given the script they're
like oh maybe I'm not in it that much so
yeah we're going to see um but very very
strange times you you never know how
Marvel are going to react to stuff I
hope they don't learn the wrong lessons
from this week's weekend box office with
the Marvels but I feel like there will
um but yeah there's lots of different
reasons why it's bombed which takes us
into our next segment Greg I'm going to
try and go through this with as much
Nuance as I can because it's been so
difficult talking about this thing even
making you you know what what you know
what it was Greg and I said this to
yesterday the Loki finale were had such
a high Marvel had so many positive
headlines that were going to be coming
their way because of how good that
finale was and for whatever reason they
decided to release the Marvels on the
exact same day as it and since then all
the discourse all the headlines on
Twitter it's been dominated by lots of
negative ity lots of arguing and I feel
bad for Loki because it's just taking
away all the publicity from that and
there's just so many people discussing
the Marvel's box office and I feel I
genuinely read some of the the arguments
and think people are going a bit insane
from it just so tribalistic over it and
look mate I'm GNA be honest with you if
you if you feel personally offended by
the way a movie performs at a box office
or someone's criticism of it you know
just just self-reflect I know this
movies like this you know there are
people who are really invested in it
because it means a lot to certain people
for example it's like if you're a woman
or if you're a person of color and you
feel like oh we're finally getting a big
film for us it's it's going to hurt a
bit more seeing that flop um but you
know if people are giving criticisms
about it then maybe just don't attack
them or go after them there's a toxic
positivity thing that Sean chanler
talked about where he said there's a lot
of toxic negativity where people hate on
it and over haate on it and then there's
a toxic positivity thing where you love
something so much that anyone who says
any criticism about it just gets
attacked and you just want to kill them
and say you hate them and attacking
opinion is not the same as attacking a
person over it yeah I mean you can argue
with me while you think the movie was
brilliant and I'll be like oh well I'll
be honest with you Greg um I've watched
it twice now
I it was about the same I genuinely felt
about the same I had a few more problems
with the structure of it um and the
inconsistencies with the powers because
I was like well how's Camala using all
of her powers at this point and it's
still I know they say in the movie guys
before you jump in the comments I know
they say I know they say like don't you
have to use it to a certain point and
then it switches but she she was
literally going building up force fields
around her and everything and running on
top of them and stuff um I don't want to
get too much much into it because I've
kind of talked it to death at this point
um but I feel the Rotten Tomato score of
60% I would score at about a six out of
10 I think after a second watch um I
think there is I think there's a am man
valani I think is brilliant in the film
I think she really carries it um you
know people are saying it's fun yeah
totally agree um I just think where it's
let down is story
structure and yeah the lack of a
compelling villain and just general misp
points that they could have made it
feels like a very superficial surface
level thing and one of my big Hang-Ups
that I had over the weekend was the way
I think they should have went with the
film is that you have Captain Marvel
who's the annihilator she completely
destroyed a planet Society she's
basically Captain genocide what who what
crazy evil person she could be seen as
and then you jump to her number one fan
biggest fan in the world and I thought
it would be great to do a comment on
Stan culture and show how blinded people
can be by worshiping certain idols and
what they build them up in their head to
be and though they have that one line
where Carol's like we can't save them
all it's a very surface level stuff and
I think they should have really dialed
in deep to what Carol's you know
kamala's worship of Carol was like and
why you shouldn't necessarily just
follow someone CU you what they stand
for and what they look like and you feel
common ground with them you mind if I
inter interrupt your opinion with a
quick little insert here is that what I
think you're saying right now is not
something that you were thinking the
movie should do before you watched it
what I'm gathering from what you're
saying is that the movie presented it
like you and I have not talked about
what what you're talking about right now
you and I have not talked about this
ever and what you're and I feel like a
lot of times when someone presents
something like that people go well you
should just take it for what it is not
what you wanted it to be the movie
itself is presenting those things and
then it rushes past them and it drops
the ball on them it it just it's it
suddenly becomes disinterested in it and
like the the actual heart and the
conversation it's setting up and then
from knowing someone need to like I I
mean I primarily only really only like
know Candyman but knowing her
involvement with that which wanted to
have conversation and decided to kind of
ruminate in some of the deeper thoughts
and stuff not that this movie needs to
be a deep experience of
sorts I I think everything you are
saying that you you think it could have
done is because the movie itself was
setting it up the movie itself was going
look at this story we're about to and
never mind you know like that that's
what you're saying before someone just
comes in and
says and I mean look every every single
person on Earth you guys know for a fact
that you there'll be some movie out
there that no one else enjoys that
you're just like a ter a brain off for
it sit back enjoy it I love it it's such
a good time and but you can't expect
every single person to like that and I
know you guys don't expect every single
person to like that and but that's why
I'm not being too harsh on people who
are like oh I had fun with it I enjoyed
it it's like don't need to be yeah good
I'm glad you enjoyed it you know I would
much prefer people to enjoy Marvel
movies and want to talk about them um
but for me just lacked in some certain
areas um and I don't want to rail on it
too hard H but there's just lots of
reasons that I've compil that we're
going to go through bit by bit and talk
about certain aspects that I believe are
the reason that maybe it underperformed
certain ways that Marvel can maybe take
this on board and go forward in a brand
new Direction now whenever I've seen
people talking about it bombing the
first the first point that comes up is
that there were strikes on at this time
um and I really hope that Marvel aren't
sitting in the offices right now going
oh well only bomb because of strikes
because I think there's a lot more going
on to that I think that's makes up a
tiny little bit of it I really do I
don't think I think Marvel's been around
for 15 years now and for those 15 years
they've absolutely dominated the
industry to have a Marvel movie called
the Marvels that should do enough and I
feel like everyone was aware of this
film that was coming out you know we saw
the tra
we knew about the cast you know Captain
Marvel was in a billion dollar film
she's been in the Avengers endgame um
opab and shanqi the wh if Episode I
constantly bring up with you Greg um I
feel that the public Consciousness was
aware that this movie was coming out and
I I don't necessarily think that an
appearance on hot wings would have
boosted this by hundreds of millions of
dollars now let's say but damn that
would have been a good episode though
you know that would have been been a
good episode it would have it would have
helped with some publicity but would
people have then translated that to to
going out and buying tickets I think
best best case
scenario let's say that adds 20% of the
box office you're still looking at a
movie that underperforms because that
even that amount and we haven't actually
gone over the figures yet so it did 47
million domestically which brings it in
at a lower Mark than the Incredible Hulk
which was released in 200 eight now
adjusted for inflation The Incredible
Hulk does about 80 million opening
weekend and that was the
second MCU film before we even knew what
an MCU was um you know there wasn't much
Word of Mouth around it we didn't know
Iron Man was in it we didn't know it was
connected um and we had a Hulk movie a
couple of years before that didn't do
that well either so there wasn't that
much excitement there so that kind of
gives you the perspective of where
things are um so I don't believe the
strikes massively would have saved this
film I think sure maybe they had a $5
million on top of it but it still comes
in as the lowest MCU movie yeah now Greg
you're the trailer Master another thing
I brought up when I was thinking about
this I don't think the trailers were
that strong no uh I agree with you man
uh the
trailers did not demonstrate the
significance of the film
and the last the final trainer trailer
for it that came out the week of which a
is a massive tonal shift from the other
two trailers and is not tonally akin to
what the actual movie itself is like
and it's kind of odd to me that the
trailers just wanted to sell themselves
as just a fun movie like that's all it
is is fun when you get to the ending of
the movie both the last scene and the
mid credit scene are so integral for the
future of the MCU and the direction
everything's going to open up the door
for not saying they need to spoil it but
the trailer's never honed in on the
importance of checking out this movie
either like it it just kind of see we'
said it time and time again like even
though I I was I think the last podcast
we did I was here with you saying that
my hope for this film is that it gets
such good word of mouth that it ends up
racking in good numbers over the coming
weeks even if it underperforms over
opening weekends so I've rooted for the
film in spite of the fact that I didn't
really think the trailers showed us
anything that special or that unique
other than yeah it's another fun movie
but we know that a just another fun
comic book movie does not suffice
anymore with audiences we've said this
point many many times and it it is kind
of odd to me to see the how important
like the end scene is and the mid credit
scene is like this significance of that
and the trailers to not
even clue you in on that and I think
they had like a desperate attempt in the
final trailer when they're showing you
like Iron Man and Captain America and
then I think there was some line or text
in there about how it's important now
but I think they should have led with
that in in some degree just so people
were like I I think I have to watch this
not oh just looks like another
entertaining film uh they they kind of
played it a little too safe uh with it
marketing uh in that realm because
because I think even Quanto Mania which
you know you're talking about this this
movie has the same Cinema score as
quantam Mania the same exact Cinema
score and quantam Mania had a much
better box office opening for for sure
had a much better box office opening
better trailers too and they also had
the actors able to promote the movie so
people were they were able to promote
the film then and as we saw though the
movie still
severely underperformed at the box
office and um but they the trailer the
movie at least it's more it's easier to
convey because you got Jonathan majors
and there is Kang that there is an
importance to watching this movie for
the MCU and I think the trailers did shy
away from that uh too I was like that
could have been their Saving Grace I
think what do yeah that last trailer
especially it seemed like they knew
they'd messed up in how they'd marketed
this and were trying as hard as they
could to make it seem like this like the
opening shot of the trailer was like
Tony star and then it was like Captain
America and then I had Thanos saying
someone will continue the work and it's
like that is so misleading and you could
tell that they realize like oh crap we
need to make this look like it's part of
the bigger picture and an actual Marvel
movie that the people need to go and see
um but that was just completely all over
the place I mean when they did that I
was like oh crap they they are so
desperate at this point because we knew
the pre- ticket sales and I was like oh
and we'd heard they were coming under
the flash as well it was kind of like oh
oh no what's weird to me right Marvel
they clearly know what people are
interested in because they put them as
post-credit scenes and it's kind of like
why not make that movie if you know you
know what people want to see because you
constantly tease it at the end of films
so why not make that movie and I was
thinking like not to do like how to fix
the Marvels but I was thinking an
interesting way to do things would be to
have Dar Ben at the start open up a
and Monica gets sucked into the X-Men
universe and then she's trying to get
home from that side and then you have
Cala and Carol stuck on the other side
and they can form their relationship
together where she kind of questions
about if she's worshiping the right
person and then you've got those two
universes and that kind of integrates it
better um it just doesn't it's just so
weird that Marvel
constantly they know what people want um
but even with the POs credit scene being
tied to the X-Men I don't know if that's
necessarily enough to get Butts in seats
because we've seen for example in the
case of Black Adam you know post credit
scenes don't tease movies unfort H don't
sell movie tickets Unfortunately they
tease ones coming down the line but they
don't necessarily the sell the one that
they're attached to um and I just feel
we we've SE obviously Professor Rex
appeared in Multiverse of Madness we
know Deadpool's coming with Hugh Jackman
as Wolverine we kind of are already
aware that the X-Men are coming in now
if this had came out the blue no one had
a clue that you know the post credit
scene was going to be what it was that
word of mouth I think would have got
more people in but the fact that we've
had X-Men buildup already yeah it's kind
of like all right okay I I'll I'll catch
you on streaming or something now
catching it on streaming Greg that's
another thing that I feel is a problem
with how Disney have made their movies
and let's be clear this isn't this
bombing isn't a one-off for Disney this
year Disney have had multiple multiple
bombs and they've kind of trained Their
audience to expect stuff on streaming
straight away yeah I agree like es I
mean they they even advertising it with
these characters who two of two of which
are from streaming shows from W like
Monica Rambo from wav Vision Miss Marvel
from Miss Marvel and then even Nick Fury
CAU off of secret Invasion and like
secret Invasion which was a very much
disliked series at the end of the day
even though you and I were in the first
half really enjoying it and then as it
went I think all most of the audience
was like uhuh not for me and yeah so you
have
that I think that's just there's so many
other there's so many variables working
against
it Miss Marvel too like is as great as
she is I've said it so many times so
like over the past year so many times
that Aman volani is one of the best cast
actors in all of the MC see you and and
one thing that's making me happy right
now is there's a lot of people I'm
seeing who never watched Miss Marvel
watch this and on both camps of people
who did not like it and did like the
Marvels the common consensus seems to be
but Aman valani she's great I'm like
thank you for noticing because she's
always been like freaking perfect for uh
Miss for Miss Marvel I think she is one
of the best cast actors but regardless
the show itself wasn't that big of a
series and they did kind of make it feel
like a tall order as well you know like
the a big part of the MCU and we kind of
talked about that this might be one of
the variables or several variables to
why Loki season 2 was not racking in the
numbers as to as what it got for season
1 and one of the variables that we were
discussing was how there might have been
a lot of people feeling like I haven't
been keeping up with the MCU so I might
be a little bit lost because there's
been so many MCU projects and the
Marvel's like there's a lot more reasons
to go through here but the Marvels
especially they were asking you you
gotta watch Captain Marvel so that's at
least two hours okay we know most people
already seen that you got to watch Miss
Marvel that's like six hours of
Television you gota watch W Vision you
might need a refresher it's been a while
it's like six hours there you got to
watch secret Invasion there like six or
more hours there so you're being asked
to watch like 20 hours of stuff to watch
this and that's kind of the ironic part
to me just on a little side note of how
people are like it's not meant to be
it's just meant to be like fun it's just
meant to be fun I'm like okay yeah I can
get on board with that I I can get on
board with just a fun movie I mean I
remember when I watched Justice League
uh people actually still applauded
opening night when the movie was done
and they applauded and even though they
completely made into some wacky fun mess
uh I even I was like yeah I still had
fun when I when I watch watch it so I I
can I can respect it but they but the
the leadup to this I think they kind of
won aspect out of many aspects to why
this might have this this is bombed I
think there is a bit of a daunting ask
of have you been keeping up with all
this stuff even the movie itself decides
to do like an entire recap of Captain
Marvel whether remember that in the
beginning of the film like let's just
not just give a couple of throwaway
lines Let's do an entire recap of
Captain Marvel because it's been that
long you know and that's that's one
element to it so I think like there is
the association of we've been watching
this on streaming three of these
characters their stories the
significance of this has been on
streaming might as well just wait for
streaming for it to come out and then
other stuff I completely agree um the
amount of people who aren't necessarily
hardcore fans who are like oh do I need
to watch this before going to see um the
Marvels it's like it's quite a lot of
stuff to watch that isn't it and I was
like uh well the people they're saying
it's kind of stand alone you'll pick it
up in the film but even then I think
they had in their head that they just
wouldn't understand it and therefore
wouldn't enjoy it and just s like the
amount of people who ask me that a
sequel be coming out of something and go
well I need to see the first one I'll go
uh Pro yeah you should probably try
check it out but you might get away with
not seeing it but I know I know
instantly it's already put them off the
fact they're questioning that having to
do that and it just feels like homework
uh so I don't think that they they they
people necessarily felt that this was
going to be newcomer friendly and the
numbers that Ms Marvel got viewership
wise you know that the fan base wasn't
there for people to attach themselves to
that character and be excited for this
sure all the stod ones absolutely love
the Miz Marvel show I think it's one of
the best uh Disney Plus shows in general
but General audiences didn't watch it on
mass so therefore they're not attached
this character um and obviously when we
get into you know it's a it's a female
Le superhero film Craig so there's
there's obviously going to be that that
crowd out there who chant that it's woke
just refuse to see it boycott it that's
going to knock your number down as well
um you know obviously I think people
should give it a chance but those people
are just never going to come back and
watch this film no matter what um or if
they and if it does badly they're going
to rag on it and unfortunately that's
just a a side of every sing Le fan base
I see um I still don't feel though that
that's enough to tank a film's box
office and I realized that this time
last year it was the 11th of November
wakonda forever got released um and that
did almost near a billion and if you
look at the main characters in that Shu
AO you know what I mean that is a very
female LED film as well um granted there
was also the element of you know wanting
to see the griev of Chadwick
Boseman a different element added into
the mix there the Wonder Woman did well
didn't it yeah and well what was the
biggest I mean what was the biggest show
last year House of the Dragon um female
characters is the main character in that
and after the the recast um you've got
Emma Dary who's non-binary playing a
woman and you know that could easily be
something that people could scream wel
at and boycott it at but it still was
the biggest show last year and I just
don't think that the the people who cry
woke are enough to necessarily ding the
box office that much now looking at
demographics it's one of the funny
things to interject really quick it's
one of the funny things about this one
is that even for because we know there's
those channels out there who pretty much
they want it to fail like for your heavy
spoilers or real rejects it could go
either way for us our audience is not
really expecting us they might hear some
things we say but they're not
they wouldn't be you know what I mean
like there's there's some channels that
if they liked it they would lose their
entire audience like they they're
expected to hate it so they can milk the
videos of of hating it and the funny
part about it
is a lot of them would scream like woke
just because there's women in it all the
time but this movie has also been
credited from a lot of those channels
that actually the movie is not preachy
or has any like political messaging in
it yeah
yeah in fact it looks makes its
characters look quite bad I'm looking at
you Captain genocide I know what you did
on H I know what you were getting up to
killing all those people in starting the
Civil War and but speaking of people not
liking Captain Marvel there's let's be
honest there is a massive hate train for
Brie Lawson online um and that has been
building since the first one people just
don't like her um and no matter if you
type in her name on YouTube there's
probably going to be 10 negative videos
come up as the first Point um and that's
kind of why I feel that I I feel like
Marvel might have responded to that but
not told people which is why instead of
getting Captain Marvel 2 we're just
getting the Marvels and they have the
The Other Side characters and look
rumors are rumors but apparently from
what was said behind the scenes there
was she had difficulty on set with
people because she was no longer the
lead now whether that's true I don't
want to say that is I'm going to say
take that with a pinch of salt um but
there are there is the feeling that
Marvel kind of maybe didn't want to take
the risk similar to what we're seeing
perhaps with Jonathan Maes right now
where the internet backlashed they're
just worried and they thought like oh
let's bring in other characters and kind
of make a a second lead in in what
should be her sequel um I I don't have a
problem with brie Lawson you know I
think it does get overblown what
happened but I can totally see that
affecting the box office especially when
you know you're trying to to build up
Goodwill for something and that is those
people that are just riding against them
um and just riding against marble in
general my next point was going to be
that there's a feeling around Marvel
that Marvel is bad right now and we have
had things like love and thunder Quantum
Mania secret Invasion and the feeling is
in general amongst the fan community
that the the quality isn't there anymore
and we're just getting so many mediocre
projects that people are kind of just
turned off to it and they're not
necessarily rushing out to see a Marvel
movie especially one that debuts with
very low Rotten Tomato scores that was
another thing I felt impacted it a lot
and to see the headlines of it being
like Captain the Marvels is rotten and
Rotten Tomatoes you know that that's
just another ding in there when you're
already having bad bad films after bad
film and to have another one people are
kind of like oh Marvel's falling off
already look at the score we're not
we're just not going to bother it's
fresh now it it just yeah they maned to
get it up they managed to got on the
phone and were like Paul was send the
money in the check how quickly can he
get a rotten Tomato's account set up and
just say it's fresh I was like I'm doing
it now I'm doing it now um but there was
also the audience demographic now men
are getting blamed for this film failing
they are if you go on social media it's
like it's men who are making this fail
but right if you look at the
demographics of who went to see the film
it's 65% men 35% women so maybe bloody
women maybe they made it fail yeah you
should show up women they
should show to the Marvel so what what I
did today was Greg I looked at the
audience demographics for Marvel in
general and according to the the highest
result on Google so take that how you
will um the MCU comic book movies 79%
male they skew so 21% women now when
your audience is mainly men it's
difficult think to to Market a female
Leed superhero movie that does appear
like it's very female driven and that
there isn't much for men in there you
know we'll go see it because it's a
comic book movie but in general I I and
I've always thought this I believe the
perception of Marvel is that it's a male
brand and I think women no matter what
if they hear a Marvel movie will just
instantly assume that it's for men I
said this last week and I apologize to
the women out there who are like no I'm
a I'm a woman and I'm a Marvel fan and I
have been since I'm a
kid I apologize for saying that but if
we're just looking at the audience
demographics the the majority is men and
just in the same way that if if someone
said to me Greg they're making a
romantic comedy but it's it's for men
it's all male cast and it's about what
men like in romantic comedies I would
still in the back of my head be thinking
I think this might be secretly made for
women and they're just trying to trick
me into thinking it's for men and I do
believe like I spoke to my wife about it
and she was saying the same things with
her friends who um they they all went to
see Barbie opening night whereas this
that just weren't interested at all
because they didn't think it was for
them well you know it's it's an it's an
interesting conversation to have about
it because on my personal end I could
care less that it's women uh you know
what I mean exactly the same Greg we're
just giv reasons for why we think it
might have bombed yeah yeah no it's just
one of the main things and I know you
and I are on the same page about that I
will acknowledge like I already pointed
out that there are some channels out
there who just who did want it to fail
right they did and that I'm not going to
say who but you you can Venture a guess
or you could have someone just kind of
be like who's Greg talking about and
then they will tell you uh heavy
spoilers heavy spoilers heavy spoilers
Clips Channel specifically uh that and
and is there sexism out there absolutely
like this trailer was met Within not the
first trailer was met with an not
apparently there's some plugin you can
get that I don't have where you can view
the dislikes still and this Trail the
first trailer was met with like an
insane amount of dislikes right uh right
away and even though I I was like yeah
the trailer looks kind of generic but
it's not it's not this like
disaster that it's getting on you know
that was that's one quality of it and
then you know going online and you kind
of it's a little predictable
that that the fear was around there when
the first Captain Marvel came out that
if you're a guy and you don't like this
movie you're going to get called sexist
it was it's just the the way it goes
right and I see it a lot online already
when it comes to Marvels I've gotten my
comments about it even though I am one
of the guys who has been rooting for
this film to still actually do well even
in my non-spoiler review uh where I
really did not like this movie the first
thing I acknowledge is the three
actresses are really really great in
here and it is not their fault and they
and I felt they deserved a better movie
like right away I don't think we've ever
mentioned gender or race in a review
when talking about a film
and and and the other part it's always
character plot and effects and stuff
like that in story it's never never
going to be about that for us it's it's
never going to be about that and you see
people coming out of in being like yeah
uh it's funny how it's it's it seems to
be only men who don't like this this
movie you know and I'm like what a weird
thing to like disregard the men who do
like it and to disregard the the women
who don't like the movie you know I've
I've seen both uh camps of that and it's
not really to do with the fact that it's
a female Le thing and I can go through
the Gambit of the amount of female lead
property I mean you just brought Barbie
and that's a movie that does have
political messaging in it it wears it on
wears it on sleeve throughout the entire
film and while that was a primarily
female demographic that showed up movie
made over a billion dollars men a lot of
men seemed I mean there's one Camp of
men that really didn't like it but a lot
of men still really liked it I loved it
I thought it was great I know a lot of
other dudes and that seems to it got
great Rotten Tomato score great audience
score as well and a lot of men watched
the movie you know and Grant and to
think
that oh because it's a superhero film
now it's suddenly all those same men who
might have liked Barbie are like but I
don't like this cuz it's a
superhero will I go maybe is there a
camp that probably thinks that
way sure uh I don't know if
it's yeah and I think things with like
Wonder Woman shows that if the movie's
good that kind of overrides things Greg
prey was another example you know coming
off the back of a massive
franchise um predator predator is a
man's
franchise number one exactly exactly and
before that film released there was lots
of people crying that it had gone woke
oh no they're making it about Native
Americans that's political they're
having a woman is the lead the movie
drops everyone's like crap this is
really really good exactly and I think
once the movie if the movie proves
people wrong then it can do it wonder
what
is another example um but it just didn't
feel like this movie when the things
released how's the dragon as well got
loads of [__] in the leadup to it that
was getting everyone's that was getting
called woke all the time it's when this
stuff drops that it silences people and
let's be honest the Marvels didn't bring
enough with it to to truly silence
people that were going to be its critics
and it just kind of felt like I don't
know just very surface level stuff now
Dar Ben was another issue I feel that
was a reason that it bombed um purely in
the marketing because you know comic
book movies these days you can often
sell them on the villains for example no
way
home um I was talking about this on
Twitter yesterday actually how
anti-marketing the marketing for no way
home was we had two trailers um it was
during
coid the the barely had you know Tom
Holland and Zen were out doing
interviews but it wasn't like Alfred
Molina was doing interviews all the time
you know William defo was out there and
in opposite to what normally happens
Andrew Garfield was doing interviews
going look I'm not in the movie don't go
see it because if you go you'll be
disappointed if you think I'm in the
movie and you go to see it so don't go
see it because you're gonna be
disappointed if you think I'm in it it
was the opposite of of marketing and I
think you know YouTubers we were hyping
it up quite a lot going look we're
telling you he's in we sort of you know
there was a big online push of people
trying to to find out and pick this
movie apart that really worked it very
anti-marketing marketing that's why I
was saying the trailers if the first one
even I don't know what they could have
done actually I really don't know what
the answer is I'm not the one who puts
together a trailer but I do know that if
you get people speculating on the
importance of what it might be a game
changer for you know that conversation
helps dir that's why W division with
this like weird show female Le by the
way this weird show that um was like a
RI on sitcoms like it's such an odd show
but people were just wouldn't stop
speculating on what it's going to set up
like one of the stars of that show was
theories you know and and and and like
this is something that I don't know if
they were afraid of that with not
leaning into it because as we also saw
with W division that sometimes uh fans
can be Their Own Worst Enemy when it
comes to getting carried away with
Theory re and then being disappointed
what the outcome actually is but this
would what this was one where might have
been warranted what the postur scene
actually is so yeah I think the yeah I
think like having and that's what
Spider-Man no way home did to your point
was was the speculation on it Multiverse
of Madness as well they had Professor
Rex being like we heard his voice well
like it's it's that that Professor
actually speculated over that um but
again back to no way home honestly I was
so much thinking how funny it was that
one of the main actors that would have
sold tickets would have got people so
hyped up to see the film was actively
out there going nope not in it mate
you're gonna be disappointed do not come
do not come to this film H but that was
crazy but anyway back to the original
point which was the the villain Dar Ben
um so yeah no way home what they did was
they sold it on the villains that were
appearing they did they edited Tom
Holland they edited Toby Maguire and
Andrew Garfield out the trailers hid
them as much as possible and what it was
sold on was like oh Green Goblin's
coming back Dr Octopus is coming back
you know Thanos Infinity War endgame
it's like oh who's Thanos he's a massive
character in the comics go the god
butcher again um for for Thor of and
thunder it's Christian Bale playing him
it's a massive get and we're excited to
see what this is going to be K and
Quantum Mania exactly you're marketing
your movies off the villains as well and
who the heroes are going to have to face
off against Dar Ben no one knows who the
[__] that is yeah and it's also a really
unclear plot in the movie The plot's
really unclear in the
trailers yeah exactly um darb was a
gender swap character you know Zoe
Ashton haven't really seen her in much
um she doesn't carry the weight that you
know the hype that Jonathan Maes did or
Christian Bale um and it feels like for
the budget they had they should have
really gotten either a big villain from
the comics or maybe even get Jude la
back or something I don't know like get
someone back who you can at least attach
to I I was thinking the Supreme
intelligence thing that should have been
what the main plot of the film was um
that could like Sean chanler again he he
was speaking about how it feels like
there's a Captain Marvel sequel that we
didn't see about tackling the Supreme
intelligence and they just kind of
glossed over that the Supreme
intelligence is like such a massive
villain in the comics and comic book
fans know that I know comic book fans
mate and if I'm like what's your
favorite Dar Ben comic I can see them
start thinking oh crap I'm gonna I'm
just need to go to the toilet and
they're getting the phone out on the way
there you know what I mean and they come
back and go oh yeah Captain Marvel H 17
when Dar Ben fights against the Earth
resistance or something I'm like all
right okay yeah that that I can't
remember that happening but well done um
so yeah I don't feel the villain was
necessarily going to sell tickets either
I think the actress attached to it you
know I don't know who that is to be
honest before this film i' not really
heard and I didn't see anyone hyping
them up it's like oh they're going to be
in this and the fact that they're
actually like in a relationship with Tom
Heston and they didn't tie that in in
some way and like I don't know that was
weird that they didn't I get the strikes
and you don't want to push actors and
stuff but yeah just the fact that they
were were in a are in a relationship and
to have that and not you know no one's
really talking about it was such a weird
thing to do um talking about Tom Heston
Greg we talked about this a lot on lots
of different episodes releasing it on
the same day as Loki was absolutely
stupid because who does let let's break
down who markets a film right the studio
Market it then there's the media who
Market it and then there's the fans who
Market it through Word of Mouth now the
studio can control what they put out but
you know the secondhand tier there the
media we only have so much time to cover
certain things and I'm not just talking
about me I'm talking about massive
Outlets yourself you know we we can only
have enough bandwidth per day to help
promote a project by talking about it
and the fact that they released them
both on the same day it's like oh well
I'm kind of burned out on I'm trying to
talk about Loy but do this as well and
it's like if I didn't have Mt I might
not have been able to cover the Marvels
until you know Friday or Saturday I
think we got the video out on Friday but
I mean I was rushed off my feet that all
day and it was nonstop and I know that
there's and that I'm self-employed so I
always just I get I start work at 700
a.m. finish 5: p.m at night at least
yeah there's people who be working night
to fives for a media company who'll just
be like oh well sorry I didn't get my
work done to day you'll put it out
Monday you know there's a this only just
pops into my head right now because you
had if I'm not mistaken before I go on
my point you said that you watched Loki
season 2 and then you watched the
Marvels after right yeah and it left a
bit of taste in my mouth because I had I
had something that exceeded my
expectations was a perfect send off for
a character and then something that was
like what the what the hell was that
yeah that singing scene what the hell
was that you know the the thing is too
is there's a big part of the camp like I
understand there's a lot of people who
are defending uh defending the Marvels
and I I even said it on my on the review
where I really didn't like this movie
that like I can see how people can walk
away from this movie and actually have a
lot of fun the screening that I went to
you know there was definitely the most
people are talking to like I actually
had fun watching that um there's there's
such a fervor now though of defense for
for the fun we must fight for the fun um
it's kind of ironic but anyway the other
point I was going to actually say was
that I know for a fact whether anyone
listening to this agrees with this or
not I know for a fact that publicists
for these Studios they really really
care behemi they think Rotten Tomatoes
matters more than trailers they think
it's so important and that's why you'll
even see trailers now if a movie gets a
really high fresh score they'll slap
that onto their marketing now like we
got like a 99% or something you know I
remember mission impos was even leading
with that they really give a [__] about
that and
if if Studios that's why I think the
release strategy is really odd
especially um
because when when I'm fully aware that
Studios their publicists really give a
[__] about you know uh Rotten
Tomatoes like which one between Loki
season 2 and the Marvels seems more like
what a film analysis type of mindset
would be more drawn to right like it's
really obvious that they'd be a little
bit more drawn to Loki and to release
something on the same week that is so
antithetical to the type of experience
you would get with
Loki it's such an odd thing because
you're going to get people because I I
saw that sentiment expressed too what
you just said of you know maybe I
shouldn't have watched Loki season 2
before I watched the Marvels because it
kind of made it a little harder to it
just makes the flaws
shine
brighter when you just like I I I I do
wonder if I had just watched the
Marvels I don't know like a couple
months from now or something versus
during this I still would have had my
problems with it for sure uh but I don't
know if it would have hit me as strong
even though I didn't have the same type
of viewing experience as you I actually
I went to an earlier screening of the
Marvels you know um but yeah too much
Marvel in one day it was literally too
much Marvel in one day and they're two
very different and they're not even
connected to each other you know yeah
that was very strange I I still can't
get my head around why they did it um
you know conspiracy theories I've been
speaking with my friends and stuff were
all massive conspiracy theor no um we we
were saying like oh well maybe they knew
one was bad and one was good and they
wanted to get as much positive publicity
and just kind of brush you under the rug
but I feel that the negative headlines
generated by the Marvels as dominated it
to the point that no one's really
talking about Loki and I'm kind of
trying to steer my conversation back on
my channel to being about Loki
everyone's like no how come you not
making more Marvel's videos about how
[__] it was I was like please I don't
tend to really make massive rants about
how [__] they are unless they're a two
hour long podcast with my friend Greg um
but yeah I think the low Rotten Tomato
score was another big thing but even in
the buildup to that we did we we I mean
you got the email on this podcast I
believe that was talking about when the
Embargo was lifting and it was a late
lift and that kind of showed a lack of
confidence and now we didn't really dig
into it that much but I saw how that
picked up a lot of steam online and
people are like well they're lifting it
late because they know it's crap and it
just kind of showed a lack of confidence
and releasing it on the same day as ly
that was another thing where it's like
are they doing this because they know
it's good or this seems more kind of
like yeah it just your imagination can
run wild as to why they did that but I
know that a lot of people behind the
scenes were struggling to get both of
the projects done um and it kind of hit
a point I'm guessing where yeah people
just couldn't do the the word of mouth
that they normally would do towards a
Marvel project because their their
efforts are split your efforts are
completely split because you trying to
work on doing a Loki video whilst also
trying to work on doing a Marvel's thing
and you want both to be as good as they
can but yeah just seeing that the the
low score for it I just thought I'm
going to go see Marvels later in the day
Mt we were lucky enough to get an early
screening so he could handle it and I
just put my all into Loki and then went
out and watched the Marvels little
stressfree um but yeah just completely
opposite experience for me and then
obviously I wasn't coming back and being
like oh you should go see the Marvels
everyone I was kind of like oh watch
Loki this weekend now streaming is
obviously a big thing um apparently
there's a report come out said that
Disney's lost 387 million on streaming
uh so well done guys I'm putting it all
into that but streaming is another big
thing obviously you know movie tickets
are so so expensive you don't want to
waste that money going to a mediocre
experience especially when you can
normally wait about a month or two
months and it's going to
be available to watching your home as
part of something that you already pay
for and I feel like these movies aren't
being sold as events and you really have
to push them as being major things that
people need to go out you know being an
a Marvel movie these days just doesn't
cut it because we've had so many of them
at the point and I really believe that
in general the bubble has burst on this
stuff um I think that back in the day
when we barely had any superhero content
there was there was a thirst for it
especially when they were good people
were desperate to see more but now
you've kind of hit a point where they're
they're mid some are good the the odd
ones good but we're just at the point
where General audiences have so much
superhero content now that they're not
going to turn up or anything now your
big hero
Spider-Man I was talking about this the
other day Spider-Man can shift Comics
still can shift movies can shift
PlayStation 5 games can probably shift
PlayStation fives on top of that with
people just buying PlayStations to play
that one game um when it comes to the
comics you know Batman is always going
to be a top seller every single month
for the past eight years let's say
Batman's been in the top sales every
month of comics um he's still going to
sell stuff but like I read Comics Greg I
pick up tons of them but I don't pick up
every single character and it needs to
take a certain one to interest me um and
I know there's lots of readers out there
they don't go to the shop and pick up
every single thing I think we're at a
point now where there's so many comic
book projects that people are becoming
like how the comic book buying audience
is where they're more selective with
what they spend their time and money on
they'll see stuff out there you know
what's out this week you've got
Invincible Loki Captain Marvel that to
me is like going down the comic book
store and seeing issue of Batman issue
of Spider-Man issue of an obscure
character you know I'm gonna pick up
those first two ones but that third one
is really really going to have to sell
itself to me and I don't feel like this
sold itself to the general audience to
the point that it was like a must SE and
I feel like we got so much comic book
content that it's got that point people
are just like I'll just watch what I'm
personally interested in I'm not going
to watch it all Five Nights at Freddy's
to to the point about the streaming Five
Nights at Freddy's was released with a
like
it you could watch it on peacock and you
have the option to go to the theaters
and it did better than this movie you
know because it was sold as an
event and U while the while the drop a
fan base and interest yeah while the
drop was significant and that movie had
shitty Rotten Tomatoes course uh a
terrible I really don't subscribe to the
idea that it's that the Rotten Tomato
score is as significant as a lot of
publicists really believe it to be like
is it a factor is it a variable a th%
but it is not the end all be all you
know I think it's a factor when
something's not got an established fan
base yeah I really do I think it's um
you know Five Nights at Freddy's film
those fans were going out either way
that Rotten Tomato score could have been
a 0% they're still no we're down the
ride baby um so yeah I I feel but in the
case of something like the Marvels maybe
when we've had enough of them in a row
it's kind of you know Five Nights at
Freddy's is a big event for that fan
base because they've not seen it before
they've had Willies Wonderland in like
the knockoff movies but we've had loads
of Marvel movies and that was just
another thing with the strike when
they're saying like oh the actors
weren't there to seller it it's like M
Marvel is such a big brand name at this
point that this should just it's just
well known that your fan base is there
and they're either interested in the
heroes or not well they didn't even like
I know strike had just happened at like
ComicCon time frame right but they yeah
they didn't even like do anything at
ComicCon to elevate it you know really
this [__] just comes down to like
trailers you know I I really think I
really think it just comes down to like
trailers most of the time for for these
things yeah I mean that's what people
tend to consume the most if you I mean
we can see the views on trailers and
stuff and that is what people consume
the most yeah it's just kind of wasn't
there I mean yeah your your hot wings
video could get a million views but it's
going to pale in pale in comparison to
what a big trailer is going to get VI
you eyes there's so many movies that
flop when there's when there's actors
you know like the the reality is is that
for those who really had a good time
with this and those who really loved it
not enough people feel that way that's
just the reality of of the situation you
know I as someone who did not like it
can also accept the reality that it
seems more people still sway
towards overall they liked it who really
liked it you know I would say the
majority seemed to sway that direction
at least from numbers that come in you
know it doesn't have like a CA score at
the end of the day the audience score is
fresh at the end of the day the critic
score is a 62% and not a 59% you know so
I I can accept that at the same time
that there is a that that percentage
that does not like it is still a big
chunk you know even if it's not the
majority it's still a big chunk and it
the movie itself has not created
a there's a passion behind the film now
that seems to be for other reasons other
than that movie itself being like an
actual great film you know what I mean h
that that people are fighting for but
not like the main thing that I hear
people say is that it's fun that that's
like the main thing that a fun movie and
there's great chemistry with them and
there's some good action but a lot of
that is
like that praise again is that's the
generic praise that you give a film you
give a comic book movie it's like the
generic thing to say is it's fun and
there's good action and you know like I
was thinking about this the main things
that people say with this film is that
it's a ridiculous Silly fast-paced Fun
movie you can actually say the same
thing about Thor Ragnarok not love and
thunder you can say the same thing about
Thor Ragnar Rock and it's like well well
what's the difference you know and I'm
like well having ingredients and
throwing them into a blender does not
equate to necessarily a really good
recipe granted you know some people they
just they really want fast food you know
and then some but sometimes that lack of
quality uh of taste does shine through
and I think that was sort of the case
with the Marvels like Thor Ragnarok
while you can still have those same
types of adjectives associated with the
experience for it one really did feel
like it took its time more developed its
characters had something that felt
special to it like there was there
really wasn't a movie like Ragnarok
within the MCU but when that came out
like were there shades of it that were
from other films sure but there was
there was a voice to it it was Tao Yi's
voice when people like Tao yti there was
there was a voice to it and it also knew
how to have like heartfelt scenes that
felt sincere they they felt genuine and
not just like brushed over um and the
story that Ragnarok told the runtime
that it had that was the runtime that
story needed where a lot of people even
the ones who are saying like it's really
fun are like yeah I think it still could
have used a little bit more breathing
room it's still it's messy but I still
have fun and and like there's there's
also an ending to the Marvel's that is
important but there's also an important
ending to Ragnarok where that really
hits you know with the destruction of
Asgard and that even in that moment that
like when you think about what happens
with Monica
Rambo at the end of this movie it's kind
of akin to Ragnarok on a different scale
of just oh you're watching this thing
evaporate in space you know and your our
main characters watching this loss
happen but Ragnarok that moment hits you
you know even though there's a joke
there that corg makes it's still gets
you you know what I mean um yeah so yeah
like I I do think that
it's I don't know man I don't know it's
just it's a it's a very fascinating uh
well kind of going off that and we'll
we'll do this as the last Point Greg I
think people are getting wise to out of
theater reactions and just seeing stuff
when it's like the Marvel is a fun like
I'm just going to come up with the most
generic review for it Greg that I've
seen a thousand times Marvels a fun
wacky time with lots of fastpaced thrill
rides the cast really shine call and
they tease them great things for what's
next I could have tweeted that and got
like 10,000 likes last week without even
saying the movie you know what I mean
Greg um and I think people are just
getting wise to it now what I mean what
how many reactions have we've seen that
have been positive for these films and
then as soon as the review and boo LIF
to say the movie was [__] [__] D all
those [__] saying that it's good liars
Liars I didn't say it was good I said
but you say it was really fun like yeah
I mean fun I didn't mean it was good um
and I think people are just getting wise
to and they can kind of see what the
difference between a reaction and a
review and I I don't trust early
reactions anymore absolutely don't trust
them at all and I'm like what I don't
even see the point in doing the
difference between a reaction and a
review to be honest with you Greg
because I feel like reactions are used
to promote the movie and there's lots of
people that go to these premieres are
too they don't want to rock the boat and
say anything that's going to perhaps not
get them invited to the next one I
encounter a lot of them in person man
and uh I I don't like it I I I don't
like I
saw I I don't think any of them are
listening to this but like when I went
to the screening of the Marvels I'm not
the kind of guy if you're if you like a
movie that I'm going to and if I don't
like it I'm gonna I'm gonna argue with
you about it I'm not I'm gonna leave you
alone I'm going to accept your opinion
I'm just going to leave you alone and um
yeah and it's just so it's always so odd
so Quant Mania I saw it with this that
people are just afraid for some reason
to be honest I get it like doing a live
stream on Saturday was not a pleasant
experience in a lot of ways um and I was
telling you about it I was like man this
is making me want to quit because I was
like these F watch it I genuinely I
genuinely watched it oh appreciate it um
but yeah no it's just like the chat that
just keeps coming in you're just like oh
man um
like you just want to be honest and
you're not even like being like rageful
about it you're trying to have like a
Nuance
discussion like the the accusations that
are thrown to who you are as a human
being suddenly you know over like an
opinion about a movie is uh what so I
get it I I I the other side of me goes I
get it um but at the end of the day I
don't think you should sacrifice that
your honesty when people look to you for
your opinion I don't think you should
sacrifice your honest opinion because
you're you're afraid of what other
people are going to say yeah or you're
trying to to
something Griffin Schiller was some who
runs film speak never done never done
anything like attacked a film always
give a Nuance before like review of it
went into the characters never went into
like someone's race a agenda and he just
came out after and he put action out
saying I didn't like it and the amount
of crap he got I could totally just see
why you would just be like oh yeah fun
wacky movie great times um so I think
yeah there are going to be that fan base
who are just more morons basically who
cannot take or understand that someone
else has a different opinion to them and
that they might not have liked it and my
first tweet after seeing the Marvels was
just maybe some things just aren't for
me and yeah that was it and that's how I
felt it was just kind of like a didn't
really enjoy it if you had fun with it
that's great um but yeah it's it's kind
I think we've kind of I mean we're an
hour and 20 into the podcast Greg and
we're still just talking about but I
wanted to be as thorough as possible and
give the impression that it's not just
still ride off as sexist and stuff yeah
I mean of course I will of course I will
but we don't we don't do it for those
guys I mean those guy the amount of
people that I have with like you got a
message the other day where it's like
I've stuck with you for two years on P
after hearing your Marvel it's I hate
you and I it's like well if you if
you've been following Greg for two years
you obviously know like the kind of
person that he is and that he gives Fair
reviews on things and if he doesn't like
something it's not because he hates
women it's just because he just didn't
like the movie if you've been around
that long yeah and that that's who but I
just try and make the video yeah I know
there's a lot of people out there who
sit don't comment on these videos videos
just watch it and appreciate what we see
saying stuff and they might have a
different opinion to us but they're not
going to lambast us so shout us down for
it and the people who do comment I
respect it and appreciate it if you if
you disagree with me but you come from
it I like mean you disagree all the time
Greg we're not texting each other in the
middle of the night going you [__]
you're a piece of [__] you're racist um
you just have to kind of deal with it
and just come at it respectfully guys
because what you put out into the world
you're often going to get back you go if
you go on the attack with someone
they're probably going to either mute
you block you not listen to what you say
ignore you or at the best argue back and
it just creates a negative day for you
creates a negative day for the person
you're arguing with and yeah just a PSA
but really do appreciate it if you just
just try and be a bit nuanced and and
maybe see that way we are giving reasons
here why it might have fallen apart
might not have worded them all as well
as we could have you know we're not
scripting this but uh yeah appreciate it
the flip side can can I just add one
last I know we've been going for so long
uh on the flip side I would say that you
know if if you don't like the movie and
you see someone who loves it don't
attack them as a person don't do don't
do that either like not you know save it
and then in yeah in three months time
when they say movie's good say yeah but
you like the Marvels that was the
funniest thing I saw when people when
people were saying where people were
saying that they didn't enjoy the
Marvels the amount of comments that were
like yeah but you thought the flash was
good you're not thinking through like
guys people call me the futurist cuz I'm
always looking ahead at stuff I can
guarantee you in three months time
people will be saying you yeah but you
like the Marvels to you so just cut it
out mate you need to think about the
future um but the rebel Moon trailer
that released yesterday I thought I
can't believe it's a Netflix movie Greg
yeah it's really good no well looks what
yeah looks wise it looks really good um
Zack Snider I don't know how he does it
I don't know what his budget is on on
these kind of films but it doesn't look
like a streaming movie I'll put it that
way it looks like an actual big tent
pole film um the new Star Wars I really
enjoyed it we're not uh the thing is
people have been asking me for a
breakdown and it's kind of like I know
nothing about this universe um obviously
it's a brand new IP I don't it's not
something where I can point to the
character and be like they appeared in
the book from 1974 so I just I haven't
done a breakdown it I think that people
who've done breakdowns on it I'm sure
that they're really good I know
emergency Awesome's done a couple on it
um so he he probably knows about it but
I just haven't been able to find stuff
out but looking at it I think it looks
brilliant um very excited for it
obviously I get called as a SN Fanboy
all the time so yeah I'm a SN Fanboy but
you like the Marvels so you scumback um
so yeah really enjoyed it now the next
story Greg I feel like this has just
been about the Marvels this episode but
uh so coyote versus Acme that was
shelled by Warner Brothers now there was
a lot of backlash to it and it's been
announced that it can now be brought
bought by other Distributors um and I
think quite a funny joke to do Greg
would be if us as people across the
World Unite and we all buy a ticket to
see this movie so it makes Warner
Brothers and David's zav look stupid for
shelving it because he was going to
backgirl it he had it back they weren't
releasing it they were going to get a 30
million dollar tax rebate or something
um where they'd get that money for not
releasing the film and yeah everyone
kicked off and they've decided that
they're gonna let other people buy it
and and sell it this gu such an might
drop on Netflix I have such a hard time
understanding the Nuance to the
discussion honest like I know there's
like it's a people coming it's a
business you know he gets part of run
English fine yeah I hear all that I'm
like but there's also like a billion
other variables to why this is such a
dick move to keep doing [__] like this
um yeah and it's like you should work
this stuff out before throwing hundreds
of millions of dollars at it if the
script comes in that should be like like
Christopher Nolan if you ever pick up
any of his Blu-rays or anything you'll
notice there's not many deleted scenes
on any of them across the board and it's
because Nolan what he does is he gets
the script reads it works out what
doesn't need to be there cuts that out
and then they go film it and that's why
I get Oppenheimer for like a three-hour
long movie for $100 million whereas the
Marvel's is nearly $300 million and it's
a 90-minute movie uh because they reshot
so much they change things I I think if
you're an exec you get the script
realize it like visualize it do that
thing with your hands where you like
create a TV screen or whatever you do it
and kind of visualize it before spending
any money and work it out if it's going
to be good instead of making the whole
movie getting everyone on board and be
like uh can we just scrap this and get
30 million back instead but it was so
bad Greg um that they've just reported
this is just breaking news now but it
won't be because we'll release this a
day later but after new this comes from
discussing film after news of WB
shelving coyote versus Acme broke
several filmmakers instructed their reps
to cancel meetings they had on the books
of Warner Brothers and that comes from
The Hollywood Reporter which was
reposted by discussing film so basically
filmmakers are getting wise mate with
Warner Brothers are like well I could
make a movie with them but there is the
chance that it might just B it and uh
yeah I can't yeah I can't imagine
putting two years of my life into
something getting it finished ready to
go let's let's I'm excited let's do it
and then just be like ah but we could
get a tax ride off for it so it's going
in the bin never going to see the light
of day and I think it's just yeah I
think the studio have just rubbed too
many people the wrong way Christopher
Nolan so GL as much as I hate Universal
I'm glad Nolan Nelly made a billion
dollars um with them because yeah they
would [__] to if they just
re-release Oppenheimer like a year from
now or some [__] you know what I mean or
like closer to Oscar pass it eventually
yeah I think I think that if they just
keep giving it like a re-release it'll
eventually reach a billion dollars
because what it's like 50 million like
that yeah um damn yeah I mean it'll make
up in Blu-ray sales or just selling it
to a streaming service or something you
know what I mean do Universal have a
streaming service is are they peacock
they're peacock yeah yeah so they can't
really sell it to themselves but they'll
they'll make that 50 million no problem
doing something else keep forgetting
Warner Brothers has Barbie though they
still have the biggest movie of the year
yeah by luck and they wanted to do
everything against it they're like don't
release it they probably were like bin
it bin it it sa money can you imagine oh
my God that' be
nuts yeah but our last story would been
covering the strikes for months and
months and months now this podcast was
actually started because the strikes
were coming into place and we were like
well that we're going to get hit with
delays we're going to get hit with weeks
of no news um so we just want to do a
podcast where we just chat and get
people on our side liking the podcast
and uh they come to listen to us and not
just the stories which we'll say for
this week yeah but yeah the SAG Afra do
you want to read it Greg because I've
been reading so much and a contract
validated over $1 billion we have
achieved a deal of extraordinary scope
that includes above pattern minimum
compensation increases unprecedented
Provisions for consent and compensation
that will protect members from the
threat of AI and for the first time
establishes a streaming participation
bonus our pension and health caps have
been substantially raised which will
bring much needed value to our plans in
addition the deal includes numerous
improvements for multiple categories
including outside compensation increases
for background performers and critical
contract Provisions protecting diverse
communities wait there's four of these
Pages can I just read the quick
breakdown Paul my God there's a lot look
here's what they got don't read the
whole contract out yeah yeah that's what
I thought I was going to do okay know a
streaming participation bonus above
fatter minimum compensation increases
substantial increases for pension and
health caps pay increases for back
actors contract Provisions protecting
diverse communities and major provisions
for consent and compensation from AI
That's all I had to read I didn't have
to read all that other the crap let's
but keep it all in the video please
we're at the very end for the real
listeners yeah we'll get the watch time
bump it up a bit up um so yeah that the
the big contingent would that dragged
things out was that the studios
basically wanted to have the rights to
scan people and once they died still use
their likeness without having to get
permission from the family sweet so yeah
so poor Tommy Holland I was I was
thinking he was going to play Spider-Man
for the next 400 years because they
never need to recast him this Luke
Skywalker and in book of Boba Fett stuff
that technology will get better and
better every year and it'll get to a
point where you don't even need the
actors there at all and it'll be some
extra just walking around with dots on
his face and then they'll replace their
face with a famous actor that signed
their likeness away 50 years ago or
something um so that was the big thing
they were kind of fighting back on and
yeah I'm so glad they they got it
because I think that's so soulless of a
corporation to to own someone even in
their death just to be like well we've
got another superhero movie of Batman
and we're just Wheeling out the same
actor that we've used for the past 50
years and putting their face on someone
else's H but still the same B it's still
Robert Downey Jr as Iron Man guys Y how
do we save money we'll use dead people
yeah
yeah exactly I mean that and you know
for the a fact that the person whose
face they swapped out they would just uh
yeah they would pay them the bare
minimum to just walk about the set for
the day so yeah it's uh it's I'm good
I'm glad that the strikes are over
Greg I mean the delays haven't impacted
us yet that they'll be coming soon
thinking into the future but at least
stuff can get back on track because it
did look like this this might actually
drag out to next year so thank god um
Aman bani she's still got time to go on
hot wings and bump that Marvel's box
office up to $45
billion so yeah we'll see yeah but uh
thanks for sticking with us guys can you
imagine how wrong would people if they
started doing press then we just off
Skyrocket like oh whenever we do these
videos after an opening weekend when we
we talk about something that bombed um
people always come and say look you've
been too negative the movies just come
out they've still got time to do it the
reason that we and other media Outlets
do it I'm just going to talk to you
respectfully mate because I'm gon to
explain why we actually do it um
obviously it's to get clicks on YouTube
videos because negativity drives clicks
and engagement but on top of that uh
there's actually these these movies
don't really have second weekend legs
and they're normally very very front
loaded it's not something like a where
because do you remember when Avatar 2
came out and people were like oh it's
bombed it's bombed it's and I was
sitting there going uh Jimmy Cameron may
he ain't that big first weekend it's
normally like the movie is still making
money four weeks down the line um so
yeah but comic book movie you on the
whole you know nine times out of 10 it's
that second weekend where things drop
off and that's the weekend where it kind
of loses the you'll see like movie drop
6 6 2% um it's rare that it goes up and
it's rare that it's anything less than
45% so yeah first weekends especially
with these films are very very very
important because you know they're
they're against spoiler culture and they
want as many butts and seats so people
experience things unspoiled and to have
it be like this not normally a good sign
so comic book movies in general they're
so front loaded you can normally judge
the performance by how things do I
remember six months ago mean Brandon
Davis best mate friend to the podcast H
we did we did I did phase zero and we
were talking about what we thought the
Marvels were going to was going to do
and we both said 500 million and we got
a lot of [__] for saying that because we
were like you guys are crazy that's so
low I would genuinely be surprised if it
hit 500 million now I think we might
have actually gave it more money than
it's going to make yeah I'd be surprised
too what is it worldwide 110 million or
something
yeah 110 I think um so it's very very
low and next week who knows um yeah it's
I mean come on women go out and see it
and and Fanboys if you know if you're
fighting in this movies Corner go out
and see it again Marvel movies tend to
do pretty well on repeat viewing so yeah
go and see it wasn't for me but if it
was for you go go do it Go support it I
mean you saw it twice you're you're
you're helping out exactly I'm still
Marvel shill yeah wonder how many people
who say I'm being a [__] didn't see
it twice Greg Stephen King he did a
bloody tweet talking about stuff and how
bad it is and it's like well did you say
it Stephen nope didn't see it it's like
well yeah you're part of the problem
then mate he was uh upset about the
movie's box office failure and the
celebration of it and um yeah which is
fair
enough quit stop writing another book
watch watch the movie
yeah exactly and I mean obviously there
are going to be people who celebrated
failing but it's because they want to
see the movie go like I personally I I
tonally prefer things like winter
soldier Civil War Loki season 2 and you
know I would like even if you look at
the the comic book movies that do well
though Greg like the top 10 highest
grossing films they are more serious
tones and people celebrating it might
just you know there might be those
sexists out there that hate women there
might just be people who are like oh I
don't really like the tone that I don't
really like the fun wacky stuff that
they they're going towards I would
rather they go back to that more serious
stuff so everything's new oned Greg
people who are coming out saying men are
to
blame they're not treating it with the
new on it deserves they're treating any
everything as being black and white and
it simply isn't the case and we hope you
guys have at least appreciated us trying
to unpick every single reason why I'm
sure there's other ones out there so if
there were some that we missed um please
drop it below you know there was some
that we gave more weight than others as
well there I'm sure you've got your
feelings about it where we should have
given attention more to something else
please this part of the video belongs to
you guys and the comment section is
yours um we're kind of talking about
whether we're going to start reading out
more like comments on the show and if
people have got really really good
points we'll start doing that and don't
we're not going to read out the ones
where i' tell you're a piece of [__] you
sh um so please don't write that but if
you do write it it's it's totally up to
you because we're all about freedom
speech um but yeah next week might not
be able to record something Marvel Kevin
far's not killed us if if that happens
but if I'm not here the week after you
know what happened please leave a like
please write us on Spotify Amazon music
and apple music and uh yeah thanks Greg
any final words no man just thank you to
all who hear us out thank you for
welcoming here and thank you for
everyone uh I did two live streams in a
row and I've seen several different
people um who are who are like hey I
found you from the podcast here so that
means a lot thank you yeah I I like see
that comment com
in yeah and it's nice seeing you guys
actually you know the views are going up
every week as well so we do we do
appreciate it and uh thanks a lot guys
thank you guys